Welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
also known across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna take a look at how
to make troubleshooting your microservice life all a
little bit easier.
And let's face it, this is something we
all need.
Microservices
are difficult.
Whether you're adopting a monorepository,
building out completely new CICD
pipelines,
or trying to observe, understand, and react
to problems within your production infrastructure across
your new plethora of microservices.
You're constantly facing challenge after challenge after challenge.
So it's nice when a tool can come
along and make some of these challenges disappear.
And Lumigo is the perfect tool to come
in and make distributed tracing and observability
almost child's play.
Let's take a look. So
on a surface level, Lumigo
is a distributed tracing tool.
But when you go deeper,
it surfaces
so much more.
But let's start at the top.
Do we need another distributed tracing tool?
Well,
yes.
Lumigo works
and supports OpenTelemetry.
It also supports zero touch
automatic instrumentation
of your services.
That means you can deploy Lumigo to your
cluster like I am about to do now,
and you will get distributed tracing without changing
a single line of code.
As we explore the Lumigo dashboard, you'll start
to see and understand
that it is much more than Automagic instrumentation.
It gives you the ability to browse and
understand these distributed traces in a way that
reveals much more information than I've seen from
other tools,
allowing you to introspect the entire request object,
view service maps,
and a whole bunch more. I said enough.
Let's deploy Lumigo to our cluster.
Alright. Let's log in to Lumigo.
I've already signed up for an account, but
it just takes a second. You can set
up with a username and password, or like
I used, my Google authentication.
I've already explored Lumigo in preparation for this
video. So what I'm gonna do is create
a new project.
And I'll call this one the actual demo
because I have many other similar names.
Once this project is created, we get instructions
to deploy Lumigo to our infrastructure.
Lumigo doesn't just support Kubernetes,
although that is gonna be the focus of
my video today.
It also works with ECS
and AWS
Lambda.
We're gonna click on Kubernetes and use the
Helm operator,
or at least we're gonna use Helm to
deploy the Lumigo operator
to get the automatic instrumentation.
From here, we can start to copy repository
add commands followed by helm install, which just
wants our cluster name, which can be anything
that we wish to call it.
And then we need the ability to create
a secret inside of a namespace so that
the operator can consume it and write to
our Lumigo instance.
So let's start with step one,
deploying the operator with Helm.
Let's jump over to our terminal
and I'll pop open Versus Code to give
us
an empty buffer.
Instead of changing these commands together, we're just
going to split them up.
And I like to format them in a
way that they make sense when I look
back at them later.
So step one, let's add the repository,
like so.
I have already done this, so it's already
there.
Next, we're going to do a helm install.
And we'll select the default namespace of Lumigo
system, which is a very weird sentence now
that I think about it.
If this namespace doesn't exist,
we're going to create it.
I'm going to call this cluster Docker desktop
because I'm using Docker for Mac for this
Kubernetes cluster.
We can copy the installation command
and paste to our terminal.
Easy.
Next,
we want to create a secret with our
token.
So now, to create a secret, we need
to specify the namespace and this is going
to be the namespace where your application is
running.
So I'm just going to call this app
and we'll call the secret Lumigo credentials like
suggested from a literal value. And this is
my real Lumigo token.
Hopefully, it won't exist by the time you
see this video.
We can jump back to the terminal
where we can do kubectl
create namespace
app,
followed by our secret creation. If we run
kubectl
get secrets
at our app namespace,
we'll see it now exists.
Lastly,
we copy the code
to configure our namespace
for Lumigo.
Simple.
Okay. Let's deploy our sample
application.
We're using OpenTelemetry
demo application,
which comes with a single manifest for deploying
to a Kubernetes cluster.
I have updated said manifest to deploy to
the app namespace like we configured when we
deployed Lumigo to the cluster.
We can now run kubectl dash n app
get pods.
Now, this may take a couple of moments.
So by the power of magic, let's come
back.
God love magic.
Now, all
of our demo services are running on our
Kubernetes cluster and a namespace configured with Lumigo.
So I think now would be a good
time to jump back
to our Lumigo dashboard.
So let's validate our installation.
Awesome.
Alright. So let's give Lumigo a little bit
of data to work with.
Let's run a port forward to the front
end proxy, which runs or makes our application
available on local host port 8,080.
From here,
we can see the OpenTelemetry
demo application.
Let's go shopping
for some binoculars.
And a lens cleaning kit.
Now, we place our order
like so.
Let's jump back to Lumigo and see what
we can see.
And that tells us our application is sending
traces to Lumigo.
We're currently on the LiveTail page and we
can see these requests streaming in
in real time.
I like to start off by taking a
look at the system map.
Here, we have a visual representation
of all of the services within our cluster
or at least the ones that have ambient
traffic running through or we head through clicking
around on the shopping page.
We can see the payment service, the ad
service, the cart service, currency service, front end,
feature flags, and so forth.
We can see that it speaks to a
Redis issue is in port 443,
and this I believe is our device.
So let's go to the dashboard.
And now we can see because this application
has only been running for a few minutes,
we got a couple of failures, some requests,
and some information
on the duration
of these functions or these services.
We can actually see the p 99 and
p 95
of these services based on the limited information
that we have thus far.
So now let's pop over to transactions.
From here, we can begin to understand the
requests
within our application.
We can see on this one request,
we started off at the front end.
It made a request to the cart service
which spoke to Redis
and that the cart service
is written in a dot net language.
Our front end is in JavaScript and well,
Redis is Redis.
We can click on our front end and
we can now start to get more information
about the service.
We can see the route that it came
in on here.
It's a when we requested the cart and
it tells us the currency with GBP.
We see all the environment variables configured on
our pod. And if we scroll down, we
can start to see the span information.
It gives us the start and end time
as well as all the attributes that are
important.
We get to see the information on the
URL, which we already kind of knew, but
now we can see the host name that
was used.
We see the protocol.
We can see the browser.
All the stuff you would expect to see
from a trace within a microservice architecture.
Now this view is great for debugging
because we can see the services that were
involved.
We can see information about the pod
and the span.
And then we can click on these requests
themselves,
where we can see here that a push
request was made to the cart service
on this path, get cart.
If we click on Redis, we can actually
see the request or the query that was
sent to Redis two.
The statement was a GET request for a
UUID.
If we pop over to this side, we
can see that this was actually a request
to add item.
And if we pop down to these redis,
we'll see that we actually have a set
of a UUID.
So this transaction from a single request ID
propagated through the system,
it's actually what happened when we added something
to the cart that also fetched an update
and returned it to our client.
Now this is great. We can understand
a whole bunch of information about the system,
but sometimes it is nice to have
the classic distributed tracing view,
the timeline.
So now we can take a look at
this transaction
as it happened in a linear progression.
We can see here that the front end
is responsible for pretty much everything. We already
knew that.
We have our cart service,
which speaks to Redis.
We can see that the first request to
Redis was the add item call, which made
actual multiple calls to Redis.
And now that we can see the order
these requests happened in, we can click on
it.
Alright. There was a get,
followed by a set,
followed by an expire.
Nice.
Once the added item to the cart, the
cart service then made one more request to
Redis.
This time, the GET request.
Now we get to understand
how
over time
the request propagated
through our system.
So let's take a look at something else.
Down here, we have some request
that took almost five seconds.
So let's take a look at it.
This request goes through a whole bunch more
services.
We can see here
and here
and here.
We've got a whole bunch of gRPC
and a whole bunch of Kubernetes services.
Let's take a look at the timeline.
We can see that this is as the
front end speaking to a recommendation service.
When we viewed a product,
and wanted to show us more that were
just like it.
This requires a whole bunch of gRPC
calls.
The first one to get a list of
recommendations followed by subsequent request to get the
product information.
Eventually, this is all returned and it even
requires a lookup to the feature flag service.
We can click on the feature flag service,
and we can see it was trying to
understand
if
a feature flag is enabled.
The product catalog failure.
In this case, it was false, so we
didn't get an error.
And right away, we're seeing the core value
of a tool like Lumigo.
You don't need to understand an application
as a whole at a macro level when
it is built of lots of smaller microservices.
We could focus on just the debugging and
observability, and we are going to dive into
looking at how that works with Lumigo.
But as an ability to onboard new people
to your team, instrumentation
is key.
Much like testing is invaluable for learning how
code should work,
Good observability tools
can reveal the same on an architecture
level and not just an architecture level. Here,
we can see that we have feature flags.
We have Redis. We're using gRPC.
We have all of these services working together
and we have a good understanding of how
that happens.
So thank you, Lumigo.
Now,
let's go back to
debugging,
one of my favorite topics.
So I've jumped over to the Live Tail
page so we can see things in real
time.
Let's jump back
to our demo application,
go shopping
and add something to our cart. Right now,
we have three items. It's not really that
important.
This application has a cool edge case where
whenever you change the credit card number, it
will cause an error.
So we'll hit place order and jump back
to our live tail.
Now we can see all of the requests
that were happening behind the scenes as we
added to the car and browsed around the
website.
And now we can see some checkout failures.
So let's pause
the live tail.
And I click checkout a bunch of times
so we can see them coming on over
and over. But we're here, we can see
that we tried to checkout
checkout
check out.
These failures are up because I changed that
number.
Well, let's take a look at one.
And now we have issues.
These can also be discovered via
the issues page.
And even on the dashboard, we can see
an occurrence of the issues here.
So, we go back to issues.
And now we can see here we have
failed to charge card.
Let's click on that
and take a look.
Now, we get an overview of what went
wrong during this transaction.
We can see the front end,
try to place an order over gRPC
with the checkout service.
And we can see the actual error message
or the exception thrown by the application.
We can see here that it failed to
charge the card and that's because the card
number didn't work.
And just to show you that this definitely
does work, let's change it back to the
correct number
and it works.
So we get more information
as things happen even when they are exceptions.
With this integration of logs right next to
the trace.
Now there are some really nice value add
features here too. One, I can assign this
to somebody.
I can create a Jira ticket if I
have it integrated.
And if we know about this issue, maybe
we wanna mute it for a few days
while we work on a fix.
Now there is a ton more features we
could take a look at in Lumigo,
but we wanna keep this video short and
sweet.
But before we go,
let's click on Kubernetes.
Here, we get a good visual representation of
our Kubernetes cluster. We can see all of
the workloads deployed, the cluster name, the kind,
namespace,
when they were modified,
any issues that are relevant
or happened
in the last span of one hour because
that is what we have the window set
to.
If we click on one of the workloads,
we can see the Kubernetes events from deleting
pods, scaling replica sets,
and even creating the deployments and so forth,
as well as any application issues at the
bottom. We have a very nice visual representation
of that timeline too.
Let's go back and click on our front
end service.
As well as the visual fling, the less
we have the application issues at the bottom
too. So we can understand how our services
are behaving
on a per service basis also.
The last thing I want to show you
before we wrap this up
is explore.
One of my favorite feature, bot would require
much
more time to go into in-depth.
Here we can filter by service.
If we just want to see Redis issues,
we can take a look at Redis. Here
we can see all the requests propagated through
the system.
If we want to take a look at
Kubernetes clusters or Lambda functions or any of
the other supported resources, these are filterable here
too.
Now, let's say that we just want to
take a look at our app namespace. Well,
we can do that too. Now we have
all of our services and we can drill
down even further.
What if we want to take a look
at one single endpoint?
Well, let's take a look at that checkout
endpoint.
Here we can see the request
and the results.
Quite a lot of failures.
Whoops.
What if we just wanna filter by long
requests?
What about anything that takes more than four
seconds? Well, we can do that too.
And you can see that we are actually
joining these filters together with and statements.
We could also use not,
The ability to query and understand the traces
across your system is up to you.
Lumigo is such a cool tool,
and here is the good news.
Lumigo has a free tier.
They don't charge you per seat or user.
You can have unlimited users on the free
plan, but you will be restricted to a
50,000
traces per month.
And even if you do need more traces,
up to a million is only a hundred
bucks a month.
Awesome.
I hope you enjoyed this quick demo of
Lumigo. Go check out their website at lumigo.io.
And don't forget, tell them the Rawkode sent
you.
Thank you for your time.
Have
an awesome day.